mom what is this we need more colonies  but that's a lot more work I'm just  talking the two of us can't handle  together  [Music]  your life's so retro do you even have a  phone no so how do you talk to your  friends my mom is my friend  [Music]  thank you  stop  turn it off  who are you  guys  [Music]  now get out of my house  what's going on  I'm fine I'm just worried about you I  said I'm fine  who is this woman  that was all she had  I remember so much  screaming I didn't want you to know her  why some Koreans believe that life's  hardships are caused by the tormented  fears of their ancestors  [Music]  it's what you want final resting place  Chris I'm coming  come here  what else had it been lying to me about  all of this is for you I can't wait to  leave  you're not going anywhere  a must here  foreign  [Music]